so
you get to new york because i want to
make this point because people think
this [ __ ] happens overnight and it
doesn't oh it doesn't it's hot it's hard
yes yeah it's a lot of it and it's not
really luck it's a lot of hard work
sweat and tears so you come to new york
to be a dancer you're living on some
guy's couch
yeah but that only lasted for like like
five days max so how do you get money
well i got a scholar i went to start
going to auditions and i got into some
dance companies
got a partial scholarship to the alvin
ailey school
and then i started just making little
bits of money you know and then i was
taking [ __ ] jobs i was i did everything
i worked at dunkin donuts i was a hat
chick did you get fired from dunkin
donuts in one day
no i i think i stayed there for maybe a
week were you fired because you scored a
jelly over everyone um i was playing
with the jelly squirter machine yeah and
they just got pissed off at you
yeah had you played your card right you
could have been a manager dunkin donuts
i could be running
and says hey you're fired because you're
not taking the job seriously that's
right right
well you know what i got fired for at
the russian tea room i was a very good
hat check girl i must say i got bird for
wearing fishnets
is that right yeah and i couldn't i'm
like but you can't even see my legs i'm
behind a door
because they told you not to wear
fishnets but you said but it's your
nature to say
[ __ ] you i'm going to wear fishnets well
it's just my nature to do the opposite
of what people tell me to do even if
it's going to cost you a job and you
have i didn't know they were going to
fire me right it was just like code
like a dress code did you explain to
them you were madonna
i wasn't madonna then oh i mean it was
but not they didn't they didn't
recognize it they didn't see the future